now according to the firearm industry
trade association last year there were
5.4 million first-time gun buyers many
of those sales from the latin x
community sally jeremiah spoke to gun
experts shares how one gender is
breaking a taboo we've seen our gun
sales almost double in the last you know
year kris chansky is the general manager
at the range 702 she says when it comes
to gun sales she's noticing a different
trend there's a huge stigma being broken
and here at the range 702 they say
they've seen an increase in hispanic
females purchasing firearms now there
are women that are carrying guns
five years ago our concealed carry class
was probably 90 to 100 percent men every
single week and it's starting to even
out now
victoria martinez has lived in las vegas
for 14 years and says growing up her
concept of guns was very different than
how she views them today only people
that were bad had guns we never had guns
in our house or close to us in the past
years especially after covet just like
how everything has changed in the
environment i feel a little less
secure
so last year
i got a revolver keep your finger up off
the trigger rochelle larson another
latina who recently got a firearm says
she did it for protection it's more
scary to be without one than to not have
one at all it's been
empowering for me to be able to
not be so scared walking from my car to
from my job it's very empowering for me
to be able i can protect my own sally
jaramillo live local now staff at the
range 702 say even though gun purchases
are up there is a gap when it comes to
training they do offer free classes for
beginners as well as classes for
advanced customers